So, we're not going to use confidence intervals for this. Now, we don't know the
results yet because I'm just giving you this poll. But let's pretend that we get
an average of 7.5 for how engaged you are, and an average of 8.2 for how much
you think you're learning. So, these are hypothetical population parameters. Mu
sub E for engagement, and Mu sub L for learning. We would say the associated
standard deviations are 0.64 and 0.73. Now, let's say our distributions look
like this, for each measure, so they're negatively skewed. And let's say I want
to get these means up, I'm going to try to do this by writing a song about the
concepts in the next lesson, and then singing it. Maybe it'll help you stay
engaged, because hearing a song can be entertaining. Maybe it'll help you learn,
because hearing a song can you remember the concept and what it is. However, I'm
not totally sure at this point that it might actually help rather than hurt your
learning. So, instead of giving everybody this lesson without a clue as to
whether or not it's going to help, I'm just going to give this lesson to a
random sample of 20 students. Then, I have them anonymously take the same poll
you just did. Let's say we get the following sample means.